they're going after chappelle i know
this story broke about a week ago and i
just haven't had time to get to it and
you know left winger is going after a
politically incorrect comedian that's
nothing new that's not exactly a news
story but i think it ties in with a lot
of of the other things we're seeing on
the world stage now
countries outside of america and western
europe are starting to push back against
some of the radical kooky lunatic
ideologies that we are exporting the
woke ideologies that we are exporting to
the rest of the world and dave chappelle
just came under fire because he stood up
against it
initially the ceo of netflix defended
dave chappelle
then he got a ton of backlash from
lunatics many of whom worked at his own
company and now he's sort of apologizing
for defending chappelle so the first
question i actually haven't seen the
chappelle special yet not because i
don't want to i like chappelle well
enough
i really like that he's got a little
tribute to norm macdonald at the end of
it i just i just haven't had time so i
haven't watched i finally i said what
did this guy say
to lead to all of these protests and it
turns out what dave chappelle said is
that is that i can't i can't believe we
got to do another show on it
he said
that men are not women
she said
gender was a fact
and then the trans community got mad
they started calling her a turf i didn't
even know what that was
but i know that
trans people make up words to win
arguments
so i looked it up
turf is an acronym
stands for trans-exclusionary radical
feminists this is a real thing this is a
group of women
that hate transgender they don't hate
transgender women but they look at trans
women the way we blacks might look at
blackface it offends them like this
[ __ ] is doing an impression of me
i'm team turf
i agree
i agree man
gender is a fact you have to look at it
from a woman's perspective
it's a fact it's a simple statement
dave chappelle is not a right winger
he's not a conservative i don't think
he's a christian
he and i probably disagree on many if
not most things
but we do agree on this and this
shouldn't be
the shocking kumbaya moment that it has
become
until about five minutes ago everyone
agreed that men are not women and then
starting i don't know what like 2017 or
something
the left in this country lost its mind
and now pretends that men are women but
what's interesting to me is not the
argument dave's making we all know we
all know that that's true what's
interesting is the reactions the ceo
comes out he initially said quote while
some employees disagree we have a strong
belief that content on screen does not
directly translate to real world harm
ah
i'm glad that he defended chappelle i'm
glad he didn't at least initially give
in to the kooks and the lunatics at his
own company protesting him
but what he said is not true
conservatives don't believe that that's
true he said we don't believe that the
content on screen translates to real
world harm so what you're saying is you
don't believe that cultural products
have real world implications right
that's that's kind of the broader
version of what of what this guy said
but that's not true for how long have
conservatives said politics is
downstream of culture for how long have
conservatives said we need to take back
hollywood and take back the academy and
take back the press and take back the
publishing and how long have we said
that
we say that because we believe that
cultural content does have real world
implications alto ira gives you a better
way to invest in crypto a lot of people
think cryptocurrency might represent the
future of money it's one of the most
exciting investment opportunities to
come around for some time
but what about taxes
right when you want to do anything in
life there's one way to do it and then
maybe there's a smarter way to do it
okay so you might already be investing
in crypto but did you know that you can
trade bitcoin ethereum over 80 other
cryptocurrencies in a tax advantaged ira
with an alto crypto ira you can trade
crypto like bitcoin and avoid or defer
the taxes get into investing in crypto
and do it in a tax advantaged retirement
account you can create an account in
just a few minutes you can start
investing with as little as 10 bucks
zero setup charges there are a bunch of
ways to fund your account you know with
a cash contribution transfer cash from
an existing ira roll over an old 401 k a
lot of ways to do it open an alto crypto
ira account with as little as 10 bucks
go to altoira dot com slash michael mich
ael that is
r a dot a-l-t-o-i-r-a.com slash michael
alto ira dot com slash michael you know
this is parodied as this idea that in
the 90s mothers were very concerned that
kids would start shooting up schools
because they played violent video games
and
the right was kind of split on this yes
the video games matter no the video
games don't matter oh it's cool you know
you see this with the debate with porn
well just because kids are watching a
ton of porn doesn't mean they're going
to have disordered sexual relationships
no come on but if you
believe in any way that politics is
downstream of culture or if you at least
believe that culture kind of matters in
politics then surely what this ceo of
netflix said is not true
so the lunatics protesting him knew that
that was not true and they kept going
after him kept going after him now he
says i screwed up the internal
communication i did that i screwed it up
in two ways first and foremost i should
have led with a lot more humanity i had
a group of employees who were definitely
feeling pain and hurt from a decision we
made and i think that needs to be
acknowledged up front before you get
into the nuts and bolts of anything i
didn't do that then he goes on to point
out yeah there are real world
implications from the cultural products
first of all he led with humanity okay
what the left is saying here that is not
true
is that it's inhumane and cruel to tell
deluded men that they're not really
women okay that they their argument is
that it's not nice and compassionate
to tell people the truth if they happen
to be confused and that's not true at
all it's actually very disrespectful and
cruel to lie to people so what dave
chappelle did and what the netflix guy
did at least initially was very humane
it was very compassionate it was very
respectful to tell people the truth
now he's going squishy because that's
that's what happens there are three
takes on the chappelle fiasco
i notice on a lot of news stories there
were three takes
that that one really can have there's
the lib take
the far left i'm sorry the leftist take
which is that dave chappelle needs to be
silenced and shut up and netflix should
never have done this and they should
they should delete the comedy special
now
then there is the kind of lib
libertarian take which is dave chappelle
has the right to say whatever he damn
well pleases and how dare you squash
free speech and engage in censorship
he should be able to say whatever's on
his mind
then there is the conservative take
which is that dave chappelle
absolutely has the right to say true
things
i don't think dave chappelle has the
right to say whatever he wants
i don't think dave chappelle has the
right to threaten people i don't think
dave chappelle has the right to
engage in fighting words i don't think
dave chappelle has the right to slander
people i don't think dave chappelle has
the right to
engage in obscenity
to engage in obscene speech certainly
doesn't have the right to do any of that
sort of stuff
he does have the right to say the truth
and he did just tell the truth here and
the truth is that men are not women
right so he has the right to do that so
the libertarians and the conservatives
are on the same page with regard to
whether or not to take down the dave
chapelle special
but
really the conservatives and the woke
people are on the same page when it
comes to the observation that there are
limits to speech okay
and
what the what the woke people want to
push
is they they say that you have the right
to say false things and you don't have
the right to say true things
and the conservatives say you have the
right to say true things but you don't
necessarily have the right to say false
things and the libertarians and the
squishes in the middle
refuse to distinguish between true and
false
or good and bad or right and wrong
how has that worked out we we have taken
the libertarian squish approach for the
last 30 or so years how has that worked
out
not looking great by my lights the fact
that we even have to debate this the
fact that this is even controversial
that men are not women shows you that
the squish libertarian approach has not
worked so now you have two choices you
either go with the woke approach
which insists upon lies and bans the
truth or you get the conservative
approach which insists upon the truth
and is not so polite to lies and that
requires us to have the
conscience and the reason to be able to
discern truth from falsehood and it
requires us to have the
intestinal and spinal and maybe some
other kind of anatomical fortitude to
actually stand by the truth and enforce
it
dave chappelle is a turf
he's a turf
has he said a thing that's true i'm so
glad that you enjoyed that clip i
enjoyed it too i enjoyed bringing it to
you i'm glad that you could listen and i
could talk sometimes people don't get
the notifications though that's a big
problem the way to fix that problem
ring the bell
subscribe
okay not just here hear me out
over at apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play aol instant messenger live
journal xanga
wherever man go subscribe to the michael
knowles show podcast leave a five-star
review if you wouldn't mind i'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you